Hey everyone it's Abbey Sharp, welcome to
Abbey's Kitchen. Today I'm dedicating our
video to a very controversial nutrition
topic - artificial sweeteners. Now I get
asked a lot of questions about
sweeteners - are they safe? Are they better
then sugar? Are they natural or just a
bunch of chemicals? I have a lot of
ground to cover here, but I want to focus
on some of the major reasons why people
may use artificial sweeteners and what
the research says about their impact on
your health. Now before we get into
things of course my general disclaimer
that all the information in this video
is for entertainment and education
purposes only and you should always
speak to your health care provider about
your unique healthcare needs.
I also want a flag that I will be
sharing my own personal experience with
artificial sweeteners at some point
which is not in any way a reason for you
to change your own personal habits.
So, first of all, what are artificial
sweeteners? Now when people say
"artificial sweeteners" they're actually
talking about extremely low-calorie
sweeteners that are a heck of a lot
sweeter per gram than your typical sugar
or honey. A more accurate name would be
"non-nutritive sweeteners" or "low-calorie
sweeteners" depending, of course, on which one you're referring to. But I will
probably just keep saying artificial
sweeteners most often in this video since
that is the colloquial term. Now
artificial sweeteners have a very
similar shape as sugar molecules, so when
they fit on a sweetness receptor found
on your taste buds of your tongue your
body detects it as having a sweet taste.
Having said that, while they may taste
similar, their structure is different
enough that your body cannot break them
down to yield energy from them. Hence why
they provide zero or very few calories.
Now there are currently eight
non-nutritive or low-calorie sweeteners
that have been approved by the FDA and
these include -  aspartame aka
nutrasweet or equal, Asulfame Potassium
aka Sunnett or Sweet One, Monk Fruit
Extract aka Nectrese or PureLo,
Neotame, aka Newtame, Saccharin aka Sweet N' Low or Sugar Twin, Stevia aka Truvia or
A Sweet Leaf, and Sucralose aka Splenda.
There are also low calorie sugar
substitutes like sugar alcohols which are either found in nature
or are processed from other sugars.
Generally, you can identify a sugar
alcohol by looking for words that end in "-ol" but a few common sugar alcohols that
you see in things like gums, gummies,
mints, and other foods include things
like xylitol, erythritol, sorbitol, and
maltitol. Now, people were pretty excited
when the artificial sweeteners started
to really become popular back in the
1950s. And, honestly, I don't blame them. If
you had a choice to either consume a can
of soda containing 150 calories, mostly
from sugar, or consume a can of diet soda
with artificial sweeteners containing
zero calories and zero grams of sugar,
it's a no-brainer which one you're gonna
choose. But of course, in today's wellness
driven culture, there's definitely been a
lot of necessary skepticism that this
might just be too good to be true. So
let's talk about some of the new
emerging concerns that some experts have
with artificial sweeteners. Number one -
sweeteners cause cancer. So this one we
can kind of wipe off the table pretty
damn fast. In contrast to popular belief,
it is pretty clear that artificial
sweeteners do not cause cancer. Back in
the 1970s, it was suggested that
artificial sweeteners increased one's
risk of bladder cancer. However since
then, there has been countless human
studies that have found no link
whatsoever. I'm not going to elaborate on
this one any further because the
research is pretty hard to debate. So
let's move on to some more controversial
and complicated subjects. Number two -
artificial sweeteners may impair
glucose metabolism and cause insulin
resistance. So one of the biggest reasons
that artificial sweeteners and sugar
substitutes were actually developed in
the first place, was to help individuals
living with diabetes. Once they
discovered that these sweeteners did not
have an effect on blood sugar levels the
same way that sugar would, they were
instantly recommended to people with
diabetes so that they could still enjoy
that flavor of sweetness without worrying
about those spikes in their blood sugar
levels. According to most research,
artificial sweeteners do not raise blood
sugar levels in the short-term. However,
other research has found that when no calorie beverages were consumed at breakfast
participants experienced a large spike
in blood sugar levels after lunch. This
spike in blood sugar from no-calorie
beverages ended up being about the same
result
when participants consumed real sugar
beverages. It's also important to note
however that this was a relatively small
study and we definitely need more
research in this area to refute this
generally agreed upon belief that these
options may be better for short-term
glycemic control than actual sugar.
Having said that, there is also the
emerging concern that artificial
sweeteners may actually put people at
risk for certain metabolic diseases.
Specifically, one study by the American
Diabetes Association found that the
daily consumption of diet drinks
increased the risk of metabolic syndrome
by 36% and type-2 diabetes by 67%. While
those numbers do sound really alarming,
it's important to note that these
results are observational so for now we
can only establish an association not
causality. In other words, it's very
likely that these individuals were
drinking diet pop because they had or
were at risk of metabolic syndrome or
diabetes.
There was also, however, a small
experimental study done in 2014 which
demonstrated that the intake of
sucralose and saccharine, two common
artificial sweeteners, did increase blood
glucose concentrations. After finding
that the sweeteners caused glucose
intolerance in mice, they let seven
healthy volunteers consume artificial
sweeteners for one week. After seven days,
four of the seven individuals developed
poor glycemic responses compared to the
first few days after consuming these
sweeteners possibly suggesting that an
individual's glycemic response may
worsen after regular consumption of
artificial sweeteners. Again, this isn't a
great study so please do take it with a
grain of salt until we have more robust
research to really back it up.
Also, these findings have been refuted by
a number of studies so it is hard to
fully explain the relationship if there
is one but it is believed that some
artificial sweeteners may alter our gut
microbiome which I'm gonna be discussing
in more detail in just a minute. Bottom
line,
the large body of research in this area
is largely observational, meaning we
really don't know if the diet soda
causes diabetes and other metabolic
conditions or if it's simply that people
who are at risk of these conditions tend
to drink more diet soda and consume more
other artificial sweeteners. But let's look
at claim number three -
artificial sweeteners make you eat more.
Now, with artificial sweeteners you're
getting the sweetness without the
calories making it easy for you to trim
calories and potentially lose weight
without losing out on the flavor that
you love. In fact, research has found that
artificial sweeteners may be an
effective strategy for cutting back on
sugar sweetened beverages. But what is
the net result of that? Well, some experts
are concerned that it's not that easy to
trick your body and because of that lack
of nutritive value you actually would
need to eat more of the food to feel
satisfied. One animal study had fruit
flies fed a sugar-free diet or a diet
filled with sugar for five or more days.
The flies on the sugar-free diet
consumed 30% more calories than the
flies fed the sugar-containing diet. Once
the sweetener sucralose was removed from
their diet, their calorie consumption
actually normalized. This was also shown
in a mice study with the same researchers
where the mice were fed a sucralose diet
for seven days and their food
consumption increased by whopping 50%.
Now, let's reiterate that this is animal
research and we don't have a lot of
human studies to really back it up but
one possible explanation for why we may
eat more may be that our brain is not
registering the sweetness as satiating
so your brain realizes that you need to
eat more. When we actually eat something
sugary,
it activates a food reward pathway in
our brain so that we feel good and we
feel satisfied. Evidence suggests that
artificial sweeteners don't activate
that same pathway so we don't feel
satisfied and we may even trigger
cravings and the desire to eat more food.
This has led researchers to believe that
sweet foods may need to be coupled with
calories
for us to feel full and satisfied.
So when we disrupt that balance between
consuming sweet foods without any
calories, we may be interfering with our
appetite
and energy regulation controls.
Having said all of that, a lot of the
current research on humans refutes this
theory and has actually found that
participants tend to report less hunger
and consume fewer calories after eating
artificially sweetened foods. In fact, one
2014 meta-analysis found that
substituting regular calorie foods with
low-calorie sweetener foods yielded
modest weight loss in participants. This
is often being refuted by observational
studies that have found a link between
consuming artificially sweetened
beverages and higher body weights. So for
example, in the San Antonio Heart study
participants who drank more than 21 diet
drinks per week were twice as likely to
become overweight or obese as people who did not drink diet soda. However, again,
this research in this area is varied and
the observational studies don't really
tell us what comes first - the higher
weight which encourages people to maybe
choose diet food or diet pop, or the
other way around. We also know that there
may be some strong psychological reasons
you're drawn to eat more or more
"unhealthy" options when you choose an
artificially sweetened beverage.
Also known as the "diet coke effect". You know - I'll have a supersize fry and a diet
coke please. Often when people have a
diet product, they either consume more of
the diet food than they usually would or they eat something with higher calories to
compensate for the lack of satisfaction
from the diet product. One 2015 study
examined the "health halo effect" which
refers to the act of overestimating the
healthfulness of a food based on a
single claim like low-fat or sugar-free.
The study found that when individuals
thought a product was "healthy" they
actually tended to eat more, exercise
less, and were less likely to take care
of their health. Bottom line - I don't
think that artificial sweeteners should
be relied upon for weight loss and if
you're consuming that much sugar that
this one thing is making a significant
dent in your overall caloric intake, I
would way rather you find ways to just
adjust your sweetness tolerance, which
I'm going to be speaking to next. Claim
number 4 - artificial sweeteners increase
your tolerance for sweetness. So there is
no denying that artificial sweeteners
are
pretty sweet and because of that there
is some concern that it may actually
change the way we taste and perceive
sweetness in food. to give you a little
bit more perspective, some of these
sweeteners range from about 180 to
13,000 times sweeter than actual sugar.
That's a lot! The concern is that if a
person routinely uses artificial
sweeteners, their tolerance for sweetness
may increase and they may find that over
time sweet foods just don't taste sweet
enough. Fruit may not taste sweet, and
vegetables become completely appalling
unless deep-fried and tossed in a sticky
sauce. They may find themselves
increasing their intake of artificial
sweeteners because hey their calorie
free or turning to more sugary foods to
satisfy that sweet tooth while being
turned off completely from naturally
flavorful nourishing food. While research
in this area is still lacking, there was
a small survey conducted back in 2015
that found when people cut out sugar
temporarily from their diet their taste
preferences changed by reducing their
desire for overly sweet foods. The same
could potentially be true for artificial
sweeteners. Bottom line, we definitely
need more research on this but I mean
you guys tell me in the comments if this
is something that you've experienced or
not. I know that when I was consuming a
lot of diet coke in my late teens, this
definitely happened to me and I am
shocked at how sweet I used to like my
coffee and my breakfast foods.
But of course, I'm totally interested in
hearing your experiences too so
absolutely leave me your thoughts. Now,
claim number 5 - artificial sweeteners cause digestive woes.
One of the common issues people
have with some sugar substitutes and
artificial sweeteners is that they may
cause digestive issues. This is
particularly true for sugar alcohols aka
sweeteners like sorbitol,l maltitol,
mannitol, xylitol lactitol, sorbitol,
etc. Which are really notorious for
causing gas, bloating, and pretty serious
diarrhea. Like in some cases, it's been
described as "napalm in your ass". Why did I say like that? In some cases, it's
been described as napalm for your bowels.
Now to give you a better idea,
just check out the
Amazon reviews of the sugar-free Haribo
gummies which was made with lycasin
which is a syrup made from maltitol
which is a sugar alcohol. I mean these
were literally used as pranks to keep
your unsuspecting siblings locked in the
bathroom as they cried at the same
time. It was pretty bad. So why do these
particular sweeteners trigger these
not-so-sexy effects? Well, sugar alcohols
are a type of FODMAP aka short-chain
carbohydrates that are poorly absorbed
in the small intestine. For more
information on FODMAPs you can check out
my video right here. But instead of being
broken down, they actually ferment in the
large intestines leading to some of
those undesirable digestive woes. But
what about the new popular sugar alcohol
based sweetener that promotes none of
these traditional unpleasant side
effects? Let's talk for a hot minute
about Swerve. Now Swerve is becoming
known as the "ultimate sugar replacement"
because it has zero calories, zero net
carbs, and it's even certified non-GMO, if thats something that matters to you.
Now Swerve is made from all natural ingredients and contains erythritol, oligo saccharides,
and natural flavor. Erythritol is a
little different from some other sugar
alcohols because most of it gets absorbed
into the bloodstream before it reaches
the colon, which means it is less likely
that you'll experience digestive issues.
That being said, some research has found
that very large doses of
erythritol, around 75 grams which is
equivalent to about 2/3 of a cup so a
lot, was associated with bloating and
diarrhea in 60% of people. We also don't
really know the impact in individuals
with IBS or very sensitive guts, so again,
this may be an individual thing. As for
other artificial sweeteners, like
aspartame, saccharine, and a sulfate
potassium,
these are best tolerated by our
digestive systems because they can
easily pass through our system without
many issues for most people. Natural
low-calorie sweeteners, like stevia and
monk fruit extract, also don't tend to
cause digestive issues. Just keep in mind
that some natural sweeteners are offered
in a blend with other sugar alcohols and
sweeteners
that may cause digestive discomfort. So
always check the package just to be sure.
Bottom line, most sweeteners have no
known effect on bloating, gas, and
diarrhea for most people but if you are
sensitive you may want to limit their
use. And claim six - artificial sweeteners
mess with our gut microbiome. We now know
that our microbiome is involved with
everything from immunity, weight
regulation, mental health, and so much
more. And that it's pretty much the
epicenter of our overall health so
personally I believe in fueling it the
best that we can. As previously discussed
when we talked about insulin and glucose
metabolism levels, there is a lot of
speculation around the impact that
artificial sweeteners may have on our
gut microbiome. According to a 2018 mouse
study, when the gut of the mouse was
exposed to a relatively new sweetener,
Neotame, for four weeks the diversity of
the gut microbiome declined. The same
effect was found in a 2014 study where
saccharin, sucralose, and aspartame
altered the guts of both mice and humans
while increasing the risk of glucose
intolerance. In the human trial in this
study, researchers found that the gut
bacteria changed in participants after
they consumed non-caloric artificial
sweeteners. More specifically, they found
that the artificial sweeteners led to
the presence of Enterobacteriaceae and Deltaproteobacteria, which are
responsible for a variety of human
diseases. While that's how scary, research
has found that different people's gut
bacteria could respond differently to
sweeteners, so clearly this research is
still in its early stages. Bottom line, I
really think that we do need more
studies in this area and I'm actually
quite confident that we will see it.
There is such a huge interest in the gut
microbiome, in general, seeing that it has
such a huge role to play in so many
aspects of our health. So what we do know
so far is that they likely are safe, but
if you are at all concerned until we do
have more quality research on a larger
population, this particular point right
here in my opinion may be the most
legitimate reason to cut back. But what
about the so-called "natural" sweeteners
on the market? Are they any better for us
than
man-made ones because they come from
nature? So I'm mainly referring to
sweeteners made with things like Stevia,
yacon syrup, and monk fruit. Now when it
comes to these natural sweeteners and
their safety and benefits, the reality is
we don't have nearly as much research on
these sweeteners as we do with a lot of
the traditional ones. While some early
evidence suggests a stevia may help to
reduce blood pressure in some
populations, it's often also grouped in
with other artificial sweeteners when
discussing a lot of the negative side
effects or concerns that we've already
discussed. So for example, one review
found that stevia could potentially
interfere with the concentration of good
gut bacteria. Another study with 30 men
found that participants ate more later
on in the day after consuming a Stevia
sweet drink compared to participants
that consumed sugar sweetened beverages.
The bottom line on Stevia is that, in
moderation, it does not seem to pose any
significant side effects. However, like
anything in excess, it may be unsafe. So
the recommendation is to not consume
more than four milligrams per kilogram
of body weight in one day, which would be
equivalent to about nine packets per day.
As for monk fruit, one study did not
find any differences between those who
consumed aspartame compared with monk
fruit or Stevia, suggesting none of the
low-calorie sweeteners, not the natural
ones or the artificial ones, affected
total energy intake, blood glucose, or
insulin levels. Aside from that, since
monk fruit is relatively new to the
sweetener market, we just don't have that
many studies examining its effects. And
then finally there's the trendy and a
harder to find low-calorie option,
yacon syrup, which while natural, has been
known to cause gas, diarrhea, nausea and
other digestive discomfort. One study
found that 10 grams of fructans per day,
which is about 4 to 5 tablespoons of
yacon syrup, resulted in digestive issues
for participants. The reason for this is
because yacon syrup contains FODMAPs
called fructuans, so if you're already
dealing with a sensitive gut you may
want to refrain from this particular
sweetener. Otherwise, I recommend sticking
to a small serving, about one gram per
day, to see how it makes you feel. I also
want to mention that the majority of
Stevia products
marketed as "natural" are actually usually
blends, meaning it's not even pure stevia.
So for example, Truvia contains a blend
of erythritol and stevia leaf extract,
Whole Earth contains a blend of monk
fruit and stevia, and Sugar Like contains
a blend of erythritol and monk fruit. I
also want to tell you quickly about my
personal experience with sweeteners and
how I manage my intake of sweet things
now. Back when I was struggling with
orthorexia and super afraid of sugar, I
drank like 4 to 6 diet cokes a day. I
also put like three splendas in my
coffee and probably would have one or
two of those. I was never really allowing
myself any true real sweetness in my
life, so I had to get my hit from all of
these calorie-free drinks. When I started
to eat a balanced diet again, including
some sweets, I slowly stopped wanting
that diet coke. Then, when I got pregnant
for the first time, I was completely
turned off sweet things and I stopped
using any sweetener in my coffee. And now
if I even have a sip of Diet Coke or a
little bit of Splenda or sugar in my
coffee,
I am so repulsed by the excess sweetness.
I've also found that now fruits and
vegetables taste so much more flavorful
and naturally sweet to me, so I don't
know if that's just me but definitely
leave me a comment below if that's
happened to you when you've cut back on
diet coke or or added sweetener to your
coffee. Bottom bottom line here folk,s
based on the current research out there,
artifical sweeteners are not considered
"dangerous" to our health or necessarily
to be completely feared. But they're not
necessarily benign for everyone when
consumed regularly or in large amounts. I
also want to note that it's not
necessarily recommended that pregnant
women consume a large amount of these
sweeteners because they can also
displace a lot of really nutritious and
nourishing food in the diet as well. The
reality is, we really just don't have
enough research to understand some of
the mechanisms behind artificial
sweeteners and we don't have enough
long-term studies to see what they're
lasting impact is. What I can say is that,
whatever you decide to choose, try to use
it in moderation. So whether that's white
sugar, or honey, or Splenda, or stevia,
whatever it is, just try to be mindful
about the portion sizes in general. And
if your reliance on low-calorie
sweeteners is causing you to increase
your use of sweet things in general,
that's when I would say it may be time
for a switch. Having said that, if your
use of low-calorie sweeteners has helped
you cut back on sugary foods, then I say
there's no harm. This very likely may be
an individual thing. We will probably be
back here in like a year discussing this
topic again because I think the evidence
is just mounting, but until then if you
like this video be sure to give it a
thumbs up, leave me a comment below on
why you do use or do not use artificial
sweeteners, subscribe to the channel and
I will see you next time on Abbey's
Kitchen. Bye!